C es to enable different nationalities
to access relief in the United States
without making the perilous journey in
the hands of Smugglers begun processing
an historic number of refugees from our
hemisphere removed and returned historic
numbers of migrants who entered
illegally and failed to qualify for
Relief empowered Asylum officers with
new authority to streamline the Asylum
claims process implemented regul at
changes that incentivize migrants to
follow safe orderly and lawful Pathways
and so much
more we have listened to our Workforce
and equip them with what they need to do
their jobs including new technology
logistical support processing
coordinators Innovative Tools 11 new
processing facilities and hundreds of
additional Personnel to support their
operations including the first increase
in the number of border patrol agents in
years the high number of migrants we
have encountered at our Southern border
is a challenge that is not unique to the
United States countries throughout our
hemisphere in fact throughout the world
are experiencing an unprecedented number
of displaced people fleeing poverty
authoritarian regimes homes destroyed by
extreme weather events
corruption and violence the regional
challenges require Regional Solutions
and that is why secretary of state
blinkin and I with the White House
Homeland Security adviser Sherwood
Randall were in Mexico two weeks ago why
I spoke with Panama's Min minister of
security last week and why among other
engagements in the region I will be
traveling to Central America in the
coming weeks as I have throughout the
past three
years we are grateful for Mexico's
renewed enforcement commitments to
address the movement of people North we
are working with other countries
throughout Latin America including
Panama to address the movement of people
throughout the hemisphere we continue to
develop lawful Pathways deliver
consequences for those who do not use
them address root causes and attack the
ruthless smuggling organizations that
prey on the
vulnerable some have accused DHS of not
enforcing our nation's
laws this could not be further from the
truth having begun my public service
career as a federal prosecutor for 12
years ultimately serving as the United
States Attorney there is nothing I take
more seriously than our responsibility
ability to uphold the laww and the men
and women of DHS are working around the
clock to do
so the individuals who have been
returned to their countries of origin
certainly know this after the ending of
title 42 in May of this year through the
end of the fiscal year DHS removed or
returned more non-citizens without a
basis to remain in the United States
than in any other 5mon period in the
last 10 years in fact the majority of
all migrants encountered at the
Southwest border throughout this
Administration have been removed
returned or expelled a majority of them
we are doing everything we can within a
broken system to incentivize
non-citizens to use lawful Pathways to
impose con consequences on those who do
not and to reduce irregular
migration we will continue to do
everything we can and we will continue
to enforce the law but we need Congress
to make the legislative changes and
provide the funding that our Frontline
officers so desperately need what is
remarkable is that through it all the
brave men and women of US Customs and
Border Protection and their Partners in
the Department of Homeland Security have
and will continue to put on their
uniforms Dawn their Badges and work at
Great risk to themselves in the service
of their mission to keep us and our
country safe and secure I am proud to be
here to recognize commend and thank them
and their families for their service and
their sacrifice but they need and
deserve more than just recognition they
need and deserve the support and
resources only Congress can
provide I be pleased to answer your
questions hi Mr secretary thank you
thank you for holding this press
conference why were the apprehension
numbers in December so high and are you
confident that if Congress grants these
res ource requests will that be enough
to take care of future
surges uh as I mentioned um uh I have
been privileged to participate in the
negotiations the bipartisan negotiations
with both Republican and Democratic
senators if fixes to our broken
immigration system are indeed delivered
if they are indeed legislated and the
resources we need to implement those
legislative changes and address the
under resourcing of our agencies I am
confident that that will have a dramatic
impact on the number of encounters we
are experiencing at the southern border
with respect to your question about the
December surge that was certainly an
extraordinarily High number of
encounters it coincides with a time when
uh Mexican enforcement was no longer
implemented the immigration enforcement
agency in Mexico was not funded it is
what prompted President Biden to
reconnect with President Lopez orador as
he has done consistently throughout his
administration the two have a very close
working relationship it is why I
secretary blinkin White House Homeland
Security adviser sherard Randall
traveled to Mexico two weeks ago to
ensure their recommitment of immigration
enforcement authorities and resources
and for us to also recommit our
partnership not only in the enforcement
Arena but critically in ensuring the
economic prosperity of both our
countries given our tremendously close
economic
relationship uh Mr secretary um you you
have mentioned a bunch of things that
the administration is trying to do um
but a new poll shows that 75% of the
American people aren't getting it what
can you do message wise to convince the
American people that what's going on
with immigration as far as the
administration is concerned is in
America's best interest so um it is
opportunities like this uh that uh I
will use to communicate the facts to the
American people as we all know all too
well uh the issue of immigration is an
issue that is highly politicized and it
is very important that the American
public understand the facts the
extraordinary dedication
of the Department of Homeland Security's
Personnel all this Administration has
done and it's very important that they
understand that the challenge that we
are experiencing is a challenge that is
a function of a number of factors number
one what we are experiencing at the
southern border is not unique to the
southern border or to the United States
the entire hemisphere is gripped with a
level of migration that is unprecedented
in recent history in fact it is
something that is gripping the entire
world number two we are dealing with
fundamentally a broken immigration
system and one that has been has been in
dire need of repair for more than three
decades but within the constraints of a
broken immigration system in the at a
time when the world and this hemisphere
in particular is experiencing an
unprecedented level of displaced people
we are um um creating Creative Solutions
to a significant problem that is not
unique to
us in Washington in those meetings have
you heard anything you're encouraged
about the
discussion um the the
Senators the Republican Democratic
senators that I've been privileged to uh
be at the table with along with uh my
colleagues from the white house uh have
been working tight
lessly uh to reach a framework to reach
a legislative solution that both the
Senate and the house can pass and that
can transform the manner in which we
address the challenges of migration that
are so very different than they were 10
20 and 30 years ago our system has not
been updated for decades and yet the
landscape of migration is so Dynamic and
so much different than it was years ago
marene Mr secretary I'll be here I'm
sorry uh most of the migrants that we
spoke to specifically in December they
come with no address to go to and
they're coming because they're being
released what are the consequences that
are going to be taken with this migrants
that are being released and especially
the ones that are coming because they
see that it's easy to get here well uh
first of all I would um I would take
issue with your characterization that it
is easy to get to the United States I
think we all know very well the perilous
Journey uh that migrants take in the
hands of Ruthless Smugglers who don't
care about their wellbeing they care
only about making a profit that perilous
Journey has been um uh reported and has
been shared with us as Board of Patrol
agents interview uh migrants um it is
very important to understand that when
an individual is released they are
released into immigration enforcement
proced proceedings where they can make a
claim under the laws that congress has
passed and if their claim does not
succeed they are removed and they are
subject to a five-year ban on admission
we have returned removed or expelled an
extraordinary number of
individuals um and we will continue to
do so as we enforce the laws uh based on
based on the thoughts with the Mexican
president do you believe that we're
going to keep seeing a clean border
without massive Crossings uh we believe
uh that when we work in partnership with
countries to the South with Mexico with
Panama with Costa Rica with Colombia
with Ecuador with all of the countries
we will have a significant impact on the
number of encounters that we experience
at our Southern border and it is too
early to tell whether the significant
drop in the number of encounters we have
experienced over the past week is a
function of um the season the holiday
season or whether it is a function of
the fact that the Mexican authorities
have resumed their enforcement
operations and it very well may be a
combination of both it is too early to
tell but we're watching it very
carefully we remain vigilant and we are
tremendously proud of the ceaseless work
of US Customs in border of
protection what are you specifically
asking president Lopez obor to do to
step up and what are your expectations
for the coming visit in Washington again
with Mexican officials will something
practical come out of that so um uh the
president our president has spoken with
President Lopez orador on a number of
occasions they have a a very very close
uh relationship and a very close working
relationship our trip to Mexico uh was
for the purpose of ensuring the the
commitment on both sides of the border
that we would do what we represented we
would do and that the Mexican
authorities would do what they
represented they would do and they have
they are taking a number of enforcement
mechanisms such as ensuring that their
checkpoints uh are
um are staffed along the migratory ra um
path that individuals are removed from
the north to the South that individuals
who can be repatriated from Mexico to
their countries of origin are in fact
repatriated and that we are able to
remove individuals of certain
nationalities to Mexico which we are
doing and uh the um the gentleman
referred to an upcoming meeting again uh
between leadership in the United States
and leadership in Mexico and that is
scheduled for later this month there's a
group there's a group of three to 5,000
people in the southern border right now
what changes are they going to see once
they reach the uh the southern uh border
with the United States uh well in um uh
if in fact the Mexican authorities uh
execute on their commitments many of
those individuals will not reach the
southern Border in the first place all
right thank you
everybody thank you so much
stand
by good
afternoon uh thank you for accommodating
the uh uh the change in location
uh joining me uh in front of you is Troy
Miller the acting Commissioner of US
Customs and Border Protection Joey
Martinez the um Deputy Chief of the
United States border patrol Don kusser
the director of field
operations the main reason I came to
Eagle Pass today was to meet with the US
Customs and board protection Workforce
the Agents of the United States Port of
Patrol the officers in cbp's office of
field operations Agents from air and
Marine operations and the Personnel who
support them these public servants are
heroes on ordinary days they work the
front lines enforcing our laws at Great
personal risk so that others the
American public all of us can be safe
and secure they are incredibly talented
dedicated courageous and
selfless these agents and officers
encountered an historic number of
migrants in December including large
numbers of migrants who arrived at the
border at one time putting tremendous
stress on our broken immigration system
our under resource facilities the
communities I met with Eagle Pass
elected leaders earlier today and most
importantly our agents and officers
themselves yet these agents and officers
manage through it all as they always do
they processed the migrants into
immigration enforcement proceedings in
an orderly way they returned and removed
those who have no claim for relief or
legal basis to remain they rescued
migrants in distress and they overcame
unfortunate obstacles along the way they
are to be recognized and commended and
that is why I am here
today we now need Congress to do their
part and act our immigration system is
outdated and broken and has been in need
of reform for literally decades on this
everyone agrees it is the very reason
why President Biden submitted to
Congress on his very first day in office
proposed
legislation now 3 years later I am
privileged to be working with with both
Republicans and Democratic senators who
are working tirelessly on much needed
reform and long overdue fixes to our
broken
system we need Congress to provide the
supplemental funding that President
Biden requested months ago we need more
border patrol agents and more case
processors so that the agents can be out
in the field doing the heroic work that
is their fundamental Mission we need
more officers so that migration surges
do not force mitigation measures of Last
Resort like Bridge closures we need more
Asylum officers and immigration judges
so that we can resolve Asylum claims
quickly granting relief when it is
warranted removing migrants when it is
not and reducing the 3 million case
Immigration Court backlog that has been
growing for years and years we need more
technology to combat the smuggling of
fentanyl through our ports of entry and
more facilities to process and detain
migrants during immigration enforcement
proceedings we need more transportation
funding to facilitate an increase in
removal flights and more resources for
detention beds and alternatives to
detention and to bolster our family
expedited removal management or firm
process we have taken bold necessary
actions during the time that Congress
has failed to act we have established
safe mobility offices to assist migrants
in Colombia Costa Rica Guatemala and
Ecuador implemented processes to enable
different nationalities to access relief
in the United States without making the
perilous journey in the hands of
Smugglers begun processing an historic
number of refugees from our hemisphere
removed and returned historic numbers of
migrants who entered illegally and
failed to qualify for Relief empowered
Asylum officers with new authority to
streamline the Asylum claims process
implemented regulatory changes that
incentivize migrants to follow safe
orderly and lawful Pathways and so much
more we have listened to our Workforce
and equipped them with what they need to
do their jobs including new technology
logistical support processing
coordinators Innovative Tools 11 new
processing facilities and hundreds of
additional Personnel to support their
operations including the first increase
in the number of board Patrol agents in
years the high number of migrants we
have encountered at our Southern border
is a challenge that is not unique to the
United States
countries throughout our hemisphere in
fact throughout the world are
experiencing an unprecedented number of
displaced people fleeing poverty
authoritarian regimes homes destroyed by
extreme weather events corruption and
violence the regional challenges require
Regional Solutions and that is why
secretary of state blinkin and I with
the White House Homeland Security
adviser Sherwood Randall were in Mexico
two weeks ago why I spoke with Panama's
Min minister of security last week and
why among other engagements in the
region I will be traveling to Central
America in the coming weeks as I have
throughout the past three
years we are grateful for Mexico's
renewed enforcement commitments to
address the movement of people North we
are working with other countries through
throughout Latin America including
Panama to address the movement of people
throughout the hemisphere we continue to
develop lawful Pathways deliver
consequences for those who do not use
them address root causes and attack the
ruthless smuggling organizations that
prey on the
vulnerable some have accused DHS of not
enforcing our nation's laws this could
not be further from the truth having
begun my public service career as a
federal prosecutor for 12 years
ultimately serving as the United States
Attorney there is nothing I take more
seriously than our responsibility to
uphold the law and the men and women of
DHS are working around the clock to do
so the individuals who have been
returned to their countries of origin
certain certainly know this after the
ending of title 42 in May of this year
through the end of the fiscal year DHS
removed or returned more non-citizens
without a basis to remain in the United
States than in any other five Monon
period in the last 10 years in fact the
majority of all migrants encountered at
the Southwest border throughout this
Administration have been removed
returned or expelled a majority of them
we are doing everything we can within a
broken system to incentivize
non-citizens to use lawful Pathways to
impose consequences on those who do not
and to reduce irregular
migration we will continue to do
everything we can and we will continue
to enforce the law but we need Congress
to make the legislative changes and
provide the funding that our Frontline
officers so desperately need what is
remarkable is that through it all the
brave men and women of US Customs and
boorder of protection and their Partners
in the Department of Homeland Security
have and will continue to put on their
uniforms Dawn their Badges and work at
Great risk to themselves in the service
of of their mission to keep us and our
country safe and secure I am proud to be
here to recognize commend and thank them
and their families for their service and
their sacrifice but they need and
deserve more than just recognition they
need and deserve support and resources
only Congress can
provide I be pleased to answer your
question
hi Mr secretary thank you thank you for
holding press conference why were the
app good
afternoon uh thank you for
accommodating good
afternoon uh thank you for accommodating
the uh uh the change in location uh
joining me uh in front of you is Troy
Miller the acting Commissioner of us
C